I the talk the Republican convention
over the last couple days apparently the
talk everywhere has been about the
supposed gaffes being made by John
McCain's vice presidential pick Alaska
governor Sarah Palin these include the
pregnant daughter announcement yesterday
a rumor started by daily somebody at
daly coasts casting some doubt on the
parentage of her youngest child there
was a firing of an in-law that may or
may not have been done for vindictive
reasons that her membership in and
support of the Alaska Independence Party
which jesse Walker of Reason first
called attention to back in March and
you know we can make the
counterintuitive point that a lot of
these things may help I don't know about
the firing of the incompetent in law but
that's a process issue that I don't
think people are really that interested
in people are interested in human issues
whether you like the person whether they
seem like you and then somebody to have
a beer with every family in America has
some kind of wacky family pregnancy
situation you know in many cases far
weirder than the daily Coast rumor the
Alaska Independence Party thing is
indicative of you know an unusual person
somebody who is not this completely
measured John Edwards type of you know
person who's been sizing themselves up
to get into the White House since they
were three years old and somebody who's
lived a real life that Americans can
recognize and in this case I think some
of these things may end up helping her
and may have end up helping McCain who
is not always the most you know likeable
or charismatic politician to have
somebody who you feel like is somebody
you know